I'm not scared of anything except flying
dude we hate airplanes no no no no you
don't understand I take a boat when I go
to Europe for 7 and 1/2 days what's that
like being on a boat for 7 and 1/2 days
what do you do the whole time you're
really on the Titanic you're on a thing
called the Queen Mary to it's you and
old people like half the people will die
by the time you get there like it's it's
crazy it's like a cruise ship yeah it's
like the ultimate cruise ship like they
wear suits I can't even go eat anywhere
because you have to wear a suit to
everything I bring all my own food you
know who got me hip to all the good
stuff was Travis Barker he doesn't fly
he flies now though he started flying
yeah since he got together with Courtney
he said he said she made him